I'm a stay at home mum in my 30s
which means I'm balls deep in my
homemade bread phase
and once you make this focaccia
you will be too because
what else are you gonna do all day?
and if you're a focaccia master
stay to the end and tell me how I can make it more bubbly
because I've tried and tried
and this is as aerated as I can make my dough
mix tbsp of yeast with 420ml
of warm water and a teaspoon of honey
add a tbsp of olive oil
500 grams of bread flour and two teaspoons of salt
give it a good mix until your dough starts to come together
and at this point it's gonna be extremely sticky
so don't be alarmed, it's totally normal
cover it with a tea towel
let it rest for 15 minutes
and then start on your first round of stretch and folds
with wet hands gently pull the dough up
fold it in the middle and spin the bowl
and I try and work my way around the bowl about three times
let it rest under your tea towel for another 15 minutes
and then perform another round of the stretch and folds
now we wanna let it rest for about an hour and a half
before transferring it to a tray
lined with Parchment paper
which I've also oiled
give it a little stretch and then you wanna fold it back and on itself
a bit like a burrito
before flipping it over so that the smooth side is facing up
she's gonna be a bit tired from all that exercise
so leave her alone for another hour and a half
cover it with oil
then you wanna get your fingers in there
and start making some dimples
They don't have to be perfect but it is a vital step
it's gonna expel some of that air and help
make your crust beautiful and crispy
the fun thing with focaccia is you can kinda top it with whatever you like
so it's up to you if you wanna make it
more simple or more intricate
I'm going simple today cause in my house we all love this combination of
Kelp salt and Rosemary
and if you oil herbs before popping them on
it's gonna help stop them from burning
bake it on the lowest rack in your oven at 220 degrees C
for about 20 minutes or until crispy and golden
but fair warning once you make it once
you're gonna start making it everyday
and it's gonna completely consume your life